somebody's I got cheating I'm like this
is drugs I didn't know there's
no rule
this isn't Milton Bradley or I say okay
they won I did it exactly right they got
the pot and ate it
oh yeah
you guys going pops called the skeptic
tank please give it up from ignore you
should be everybody I owe you a few
events a lot and I forgot three tickets
Joe Rogan my buddy and uh I like to get
high I'd like to get super high
go to USC but the first three or four
were really fun you know it's exciting
people punching each other but then it
got boring after a little bit so
I needed to get blasted by marijuana
edibles yeah my friends like how do you
smuggle them in like in your stomach
that's smuggling it's busy if your
parking lot eat that and then plug
it have a great time at the USD it's
like six hours long it was possibly
glass sometimes six seven hours and we'd
LA we have to Bent this you just go to
dispensary like gentlemen stop
by a store - what are you doing like I'm
going to a UFC event oh I got just the
take for you and they'll touch it pick
one out they'll help you with it -
anyway so we take these top red strips
because if I had the pop breast strips
the marijuana breast strips no all right
well there you've had them they're great
they come to - a pack they're in those
little like little Ziploc bags ones
it'll like that big the ones that are
like only for drugs
there's nothing else you have to keep
fresh in that side okay I'll do it but
you have to keep one Appleseed from
going sour how they manufacture those I
think they're for anything else if we
hair on crack and a little bit
of hot edible so their breast chip
they're like Listerine breast juice but
they have I don't know how they make
them scientists pothead scientists
that's look marijuana in them and they
kitchen the proper dose is half of one
they come two to a pack so it's a party
for four and I yeah you have to fold it
in half increase it in a tear in half if
you wait half the other person gets out
it does not make your breath smell good
by the way
yeah it makes it smell like weed you got
you need a real press trip after you're
done with it so one time I took a full
one
oh no I took one and a quarter because
somebody wasn't going to join in so
we're like it let's just keep going
I was high for 27 hours yeah too long to
be high for I woke in the morning I'm
really groggy and then by 3:00 p.m. like
why am I still drugged I'm high as
don't super high so I take up with Joey
Diaz we take and we sit there like I
kind of feel them and after a while yeah
I feel like you just get blasted it's a
fun way to watch the fights it really is
it's hard to score the cards like score
the round the who's winning like I don't
know they're both trying really hard
I know the book you're sweating so maybe
one round of peace I don't know yeah but
somebody does get like he won 3-0 30 27
like I'm so close it was like it was a
blowout like well I don't know man I
don't know the best way to watch fights
and I would tell people on podcast stuff
and on Twitter how I did it and people I
thought sounds so cool and after a while
I was like I feel bad for the people who
can't live life like the California
person does you know doesn't have access
to the medical grade marijuana we
have all the time so I decided I was
going to like bring some to Vegas to a
fight and just give him to a fan and
just let him watch the UFC the way I
watched you up see but he obliterated
out of my mind and I marijuana to vote
instead of just handing it to somebody I
decided I was going to have a scavenger
hunt yeah so Rogan does the weigh-ins on
Friday Friday afternoons and then the
fights are on Saturday night so half the
half the stadium will get shut down to
the weigh-ins and I can walk back there
with some sliced access a half of the
MGM Grand Garden Arena I could walk
around and I just did stuff I just there
like that small II hide anywhere so I
taped into the bottom of a men's
bathroom sink and then I made it much of
it was like in the second floor I made a
bunch of clues and I put him on Twitter
like every two minutes I timed him out
for when the fight started the next day
one was like if you want to get high go
up a level you know that made every
second floor you know and then like
don't forget to relieve yourself before
a long trip like that and
eventually somebody got to the bathroom
we fall the clues got to the bathroom
again I think it's here and went
underneath the sink and pulled off this
little drug bag and he did it he
had a great time
yeah I felt like Robin Hood everybody it
was wonderful the power of giving and I
started doing it more and more I got off
on it 20 bucks you can make them a day I
would take Mike dictate into a pillar
like down here just this small you know
you just tape it right there I went to
see if somebody found it I was walking
by the section it was in like there's
like three fights later and went by like
those two like sick and so uh sure comes
by it he goes what you're looking for is
no longer here I gets a bunch of people
to come by like suction because that's
the thing I don't sweet Mike hey party's
over somebody found it I just like put
the clues out and then when somebody
gets it they get it oh great
it's so much fun and I started doing a
comedy shows too one time I just taped
those pot of the breast chips to the
bottom of a chair in Philadelphia and I
wrote on Twitter I was like if any but
no clues it was like if you follow me
look into your chair if you find it you
get it if not somebody the next she'll
get it if not coming next I'll get it
so the very first show Wednesday night
these two like 22 year old kids they
just waited till the show is over and
went under all the chairs connect stop
it
somebody's I got cheating I'm like this
is drug hiding there's no
and so rule wasn't built in Bradley
alright ok they won I did it exactly
right they got the pot and ate it so
yeah it was a lot of fun what time I hit
a lollipop in Austin outside in the
parking lot outside cap city comedy club
and so pregnant lady found it yeah she's
like is this safe to eat I'm like I
don't think I've done any Studies on
that at all so yeah I would eat it
better safe than sorry you know because
what if she didn't need it and then they
do test like years later and they find
out it would have been stayed and she
didn't need it
she'd never forgive herself there was
better safe than sorry rings the parents
are running around so I friends it like
you get in trouble like I'm mocking get
in trouble I'll be fine I'll be totally
fine because I'm a good person you know
like Robin Hood Robin Hood they get in
trouble today anyway that's my story
so I was in the Mall of America and
people are you going to bring those
going to do what we call the hunt for
the edible that's what I did that was a
hashtag on Twitter for the edible and I
would delete all the clues after
somebody found him I would go back there
and I'm talking to leave them all anyway
symbol of America what better place to
bring drugs you know so I hid I
hid these uh marijuana breath strips in
an underwear aisle but Jake room at the
Mall of America yeah there was a there
was a comedy club upstairs Rick rumsen's
House of comedy was all the way upstairs
and I hid it and I made a bunch of clues
like I mean this is big malls America's
massive it was like 50 people running
around the Mall of America looking for
these hot restroom and anyway I said all
the clues not like Auto like relief so
every two minutes one would go out and
then I was outside my shell getting
ready to go on was just texting and uh
all the Nerds sudden I heard somebody
it's my right Ari so we talked to you
and I looked up and it was a ball of
America cop yeah I thought my left was a
Minneapolis like state trooper and I was
like wow
all right and uh I was like what's
going on and they go did you hide drugs
in the underwear aisle of a j.crew and I
mean I was gonna deny it but that wasn't
a lucky guess you know
like they must have already known at
some point they're not just going to
random people to high scores it accrues
hydrogen's Jago underwear I'll do hard
drugs a dick no so I was like yeah I did
so and they're like it's super illegal
here I'm like yeah obviously I'm really
scared
by the way mall cops in general you go
themselves they don't have any
power whatsoever
I was with dice once and he was smoking
in a mall I think the Beverly Center I
don't think what are you doing man you
can't smoke in a mall and it goes really
I'm smoking so huh and then uh and then
some vault cop comes up he gonna put
that cigarette out because okay let me
put it stands and I was like they're
sorry and then I I never walk away I'm
like see you got troubles like no I
smoked up a cigarette you smoke done the
point guys man good point so uh
but these Mall of America cops you're
like top shelf of those shitty mall cops
they're the best of the best they have
their own jail and so so I had to talk
out my way out of with the mall cop and
with the state trooper and so
Rick rusted he got on the phone he lived
in Edmonton gave all in the comment that
he got on the phone with me because
phone smile I'm gonna talk to you don't
smoke they're looking at you so come
under when I say like act like I'm
yelling I guess I don't know he goes
first of all I don't give a I know
there's an early booking for you but
we'll have you back to worry about it
but I can talk about a tough with the
mall cops they wanted to ban you from
the ball forever but that's not going to
happen but I guess what did you hide a
stood in H&M and I was like no
is that where people are saying because
yeah like not I mean help yeah keep
setting that sounds way cooler but no I
hit marijuana at a j.crew and he goes
put enzyme against marijuana breast
trips he goes they make your breath
smell good no they do not
they make it smell awful and he goes
well lifted okay you're for sure going
to jail I guess right up with the mall
cop with a Minneapolis trooper like
you're going to jail
but I need you to do me a favor man next
time you come like you gotta bring me
one of those breath strips it's like all
right fine and so I got back they start
calling like a headlight anyone else in
town that could headline the show
because I'm not going to be able to you
know write down some fan by the way came
over last night my fans give me like
weed on the road which is pretty cool
and uh some lady she's that into a
person Acorah guy talk to you but
because the cops are like behind me by
five feet and I was collecting them how
do you like you know it's that thing
when you open up the door and a cop
they're like everything all right like
you it everything's funny but I had to
stay without to hang it you know and so
I was like good it but then it was a
swedish fish so so anyway so there's
minneapolis trooper is explain to me
what happened here and i was like i hide
you know
marijuana across the country in like
different areas to give people the
experience what it's like to live in
California and he was like you sell this
stuff like no I don't sell it I just
give it away I'm like Johnny Appleseed I
guess sorry Appa weed for sure I
said instead and I'm like first of all
how did you find out that I did that and
he goes here's your Twitter feed man
it's just a list of Clue it's just you
going here the drugs I'm about to hide
I'm an excellent like here's where I'm
hiding the drugs and then 17
clues on how to find a place where you
hid the drugs like I might get my
Detective badge for this and I
guess what happened was the first guy to
follow the clue went in there found it
went right to the underwear I was like
up here dude again and they left and if
somebody else was following a good like
two minutes behind and they went in
there and they go nothing's there and
they go to must be here somewhere
sir go and sit around and the
other we're out of it a crew it's like I
kicked out and then five minutes later
somebody else would come in and serve
for the drugs it happened like
eight or nine times to them like a weird
of the worst terrorist attack of all
time so that somebody called one of the
employees was like hey I saw this some
drugs being hidden saying and they found
it super easy to find me and so this cop
is like all right so explain it it's
marijuana inside inside a breast rip
them again he asked me the same to make
your breath smell notes well
and I think he thought I was just like a
good person I guess and I was I didn't
have any ill intention I wasn't selling
I was trying to make a profit I was just
giving it to people
Johnny afterward and he goes he goes
don't explain this to me
was it a real press trip it was a
marijuana breast stroke and I was I was
in marijuana crunch tripped and he goes
in the room
was it a real breast shift was it a
marijuana bust trip and I was like you
know no you didn't hear what I just said
hold of the answer idiot I'm
hard of hearing the marijuana
breath trip he goes no idiot listen to
what I'm saying to you out loud what are
you looking here me was it a real brush
tip or was it a marijuana press trip and
I was like all right oh man I
misunderstood the question completely
the last few times I did not get that at
all now that I hear it completely I
thought he could strike from the record
by other two answers which was
absolutely wrong that was the real press
trip I hit a real breast Ripper an
injector underwear aisle and he goes
well then that's just mischief so I
don't be able to crime here go apologize
to the manager the j.crew and he left me
off and that is when I figured out what
white privilege is
[Applause]